we need to talk about Nigeria you know
Africa's largest economy the home of
this guy Fela the birthplace of the
second largest movie industry in terms
of output Nollywood is all over Netflix
Legos kouga's and the place that knows
how to throw a party just YouTube
Nigerian weddings trust me while all
that could be at risk
yeah I've had this situation whereby
people who feel disgruntled think that
they need to take their claim ethnic
tensions may fracture they're still very
young nation if you don't like group of
people then we allow them to go the
treatment we are receiving and that's
not the only thing threatening it so
what does that have to do with you or me
or any of us well everything because
guess what what happens to Nigeria has
international implications
I mean Nigeria is the source of the
United States most educated immigrants
hey fam I mean my an this is a J plus
and this Sunday we're on the hunt for
the future of Niger
[Music]
let's start with the basics Nigeria is a
diverse place with more than 500 ethnic
groups and languages and thanks to its
British colonial past its official
language is English the country is
evenly split between Muslims who mostly
live in the north and Christians who
mostly reside in the south go they don't
exclusively live in those regions
Nigeria is a tween compared to other
countries
it's only 57 years old it gained its
independence on October 1st 1960 like so
many other nations Nyjah has had ethnic
tensions in the past and right now
there's one in particular causing tons
of chatter and no this has absolutely
nothing to do with Boko Haram a
secessionist group in southeastern
Nigeria wants to create its own country
called Biafra if this dissension sounds
familiar to you that's because it's a
21st century cover of the 1967 original
the Nigerian civil war that's when three
states seceded to create Biafra just a
few years after the nation gained
independence
the war had fierce fighting between the
Nigerian government who saw the
secessionist as rebels and the be
Ephron's who wanted an independent state
for the ebo people it also generated a
humanitarian crisis people starve
because of inaccessibility to food other
countries tried to help but their aid
couldn't get to the suffering because
the warring sides couldn't agree on how
to distribute it like this report from
the air shows by ephra lost 1/3 of its
territory but I found no switch he's
fighting for - the Army is fighting a
hopeless war the people are beginning to
get tired the conflict that began in
1967 ended in 1970 with this surrender
but now a British Nigerian political
activist named Nandi Kanu is looking to
get what his predecessors didn't a new
nation they were fathers fought stopped
the reason why they fought is till that
Connie was detained without trial from
October 2015 until April 2017 when he
was released on bail things really
heated up in the fall the government
declared Kanu and the indigenous people
of by our group terrorists in September
2017 it's a controversial move that
caused Nigeria to declare the
classification a pronouncement instead
of an official designation
it also pushed Kanu into hiding and has
helped stir civil war fears as tuk-tuk
intensifies everything that any man can
do to be free we are going to do there
are some Nigerians who want Kanye's
vision of a country dedicated to the
nation's third largest ethnic group the
ebo I hope that one day if your friend
more surely what relies but the majority
of Nigerians don't support this movement
and they seek to avoid separation I
don't need to go back before that
because I've been with this I thought so
what are the odds of a civil war
severing Nigeria well Jennifer cook of
the center of Strategic and
International Studies says it's very
unlikely the country has too much at
stake and while there are many divisions
there is also a lot of interdependence
among those various groups cook also
says the government would try to quickly
squash any fight we're a separatist
conflict to escalate I think it could be
quite bloody but I think the full force
of the Nigerian government would be
brought to bear on it the separatist
agenda isn't the only thing able to
limit Nigeria's potential as an economic
powerhouse Nigerian writer and scholar I
Kennedy silk'n says many citizens are
dissatisfied and have sought ways to
express their frustration with the
government it's not the ego or Biafra
just the latest in a series of attempt
by disgruntled Nigerians to express give
us cc violence between herders and
farmers over competition for land Boko
Haram and the environmental disaster of
oil spills then he's a strong smell of
oil in the air so much so that the
community awarness not to light a match
cook says the biggest deterrent to
Nigeria's success isn't a revival of the
afro talk it's the fact that country is
having to split its focus if the country
is distracted with conflict in Biafra
oil shutdowns in the Niger Delta
insurgency in the north agriculture and
pastillas conflict you know it gets away
from doing the things like investing in
infrastructure and education and health
that are going to make the country
really succeed
Nigeria's dealing with all of those
issues in a country without economic
equity at Ashok own believes the
financial inequality is Nigerians
biggest obstacle country's total Iran is
very unjust the West belong to the
country is stolen by various tiny elite
and yes very vast discrepancy in terms
of you know very few people having a lot
of money and make sure it having none
the disparity is stunning in a country
of 186 million Nigeria has at least 86
million people living in poverty let me
do that math for you that's 46 percent
of the population one recent analysis
ranked Nigeria's commitment to reducing
inequality last out of 152 countries
that's below Myanmar Bahrain Panama and
the 23rd ranked United States the report
says the inequality got much worse
between 2004 and 2010 with tax waivers
benefiting the upper-class
and legislators getting some of the
highest earnings in the world mm-hmm
it's so odd it feels like I've heard the
same complaints about income inequality
about another resource rich country with
a large population ethnic and regional
divisions but that's another video
before we can really think about
anything even how to deal with basic
Poland it has to be senators with
justice thanks to desertification the
loss of grazing land and settlement
expansion nomadic herders from northern
Nigeria and the farming communities in
central and southern zones are fighting
for land the escalation cost 2,500
deaths in 2016 and the International
Crisis Group says the federal and state
response has been poor so what does
justice look like in Niger justice could
mean doing something for the 40,000
Nigerians who are suing shell in the UK
they say the oil giant has caused
decades of oil spills in the region
which has led to contaminated water the
underground water here is polluted with
very high level of benzene that could
cause cancer the oil has come from
regions that have been extremely poor a
lot of damage done to traditional
livelihoods because of environmental
disasters where we
expecting that by now that would be
cleaned up you go with our cleanup you
can watch it you will see that nothing
can go no business can go here or
justice could mean Nigeria being much
more efficient with its resources with
all that oil Nigeria still imports
refined products it's never been able to
get its own refineries up and running
and there's all of those kinds of policy
distortions that are keeping Nigeria
from becoming kind of the economic giant
hey guys I was so excited to do this
piece because I'm a first-generation
Nigerian American and one of the things
that I left out of the piece was the
fact that by 2050 Nigeria will be the
third most populous nation on the planet
even surpassing the United States so
tell me what other stories you want us
to cover and don't forget to Like share
and subscribe come back next Sunday for
another awesome video though probably
not about Nigeria